who are some actors that you admire oh
man that's hard there's so many I really
like Joseph gordon-levitt a lot he's
really cool and he's a great example of
someone who started out young and really
made a great transition Leonardo
DiCaprio's great jeremy renner is really
good a lot of a lot of people I really
like what about classes like actors who
have passed on from Steve McQueen okay
awesome and Steve McQueen James Dean
there they're all great you know there's
something you can learn from everyone
for Brando there's a lot of great great
great examples of uh you know people
learn from it and see and and that's the
thing as you look at someone like Steve
McQueen he was uniquely Steve McQueen
and I think that that's always an
important perspective to keep is be
yourself and bring yourself to every
role so have you studied them if you
like I mean just watched every film turn
the sound down watch how they move do
you know you know I watched probably
first as a fan and then uh I read a lot
of interviews I wanted me to watch a lot
of movies but I read a lot of interviews
of people like if I like someone I see
that especially if they're starting to
pop I see what they're doing in and see
kind of what other people have in common
with you know other people who are doing
really well in my field I think that
it's a smart thing to read interview see
what they did you know see what they
they said that worked the things they
said that didn't work but yeah I watch a
lot of movies both you know older and
contemporary and just a lot of times I'm
watching as a fan honestly because I
love movies that's why that's why I do
this but yeah I mean there's a lot
especially if it's something that like
you get this the SAG screeners for
what's gonna be nominated those I
definitely try to watch critically and
be like what you know that was really
interesting choice that that person made
or like loved Foxcatcher this last year
that was my favorite that and whiplash I
really liked
you